they say you should never meet your
Heroes but I think when it comes to
Keanu Reeves that really doesn't apply
because there are so many stories of the
Cayman being amazing to people it's hard
to believe he's even of this Earth I
decided to take a closer look at how
Keanu Reeves is like the best person in
the world okay for starters the man is
respectful to women in 2019 photos of
Keanu posing with female fans went viral
on Twitter and for an awesome reason it
was pointed out that when he takes a pic
with any female fan he won't rest his
hand on their shoulder or any part of
their body for that matter instead he
holds his hand a few inches away from
them so they don't feel like their space
is being invaded especially when they're
meeting someone who they probably look
up to the phrase respectful King was
soon tossed around Twitter as more and
more photos like this popped up